en indre-et-loire pauline la pâtissière
va maintenant s'attaquer à la
fabrication de la spécialité du cru les
macarons de cormery je vais rencontrer
pascal de hbo qui va m'apprendre tous
les secrets on y va bonjour je suis
pauline je cherche pascal j'imagine que
c'est ou chez moi alors très bien
shirani des bonnes connaissances et
maintenant place à la pratique
j'ai su sent prête pour patty ses
premières étapes il faut peser
l'ingrédient principal la poudre
d'amandes ça ça s'appelle une main voilà
que j'apprends quelque chose voilà une
main voilà hockey avec délicatesse et
amour
combien de gardiens au kilo 2 kg co
vient de jeter une petite joueuse de
kelowna on va faire combien de macarons
alors là on va
logiquement faire 300 350 magasins parce
que je fais dans ma cuisine on voit là
parce qu'elle rajoute maintenant le
sucre et les blancs 2 avec les blancs 2
pascal à une astuce pour ne pas rater sa
patte et obtenir la texture parfaite
je ne sais pas ce que la poudre
d'amandes va boire et après ça va être
touché d'accord à huy donc à l'instinct
donc on va sur un petit test rockets
donc voilà notre boss de potes
on voit bien que c'est non pas de bien
solide un cas de l'amendé du surcroît
c'est
pourquoi beaucoup de chutes à l'époque
les moines s'en servait comme aumônier
des changes mettait du miel aussi dans
le sucre le miel s'était grande
conservation et c'est ce qu'on appelle
un gâteau de voyage de voyage tout seul
c'est une boucle
voilà mais c'est lourd ont convoyé le
genre dimanche cette machine le chef
pâtissier la fabriquer lui même il
l'appelle le poussoir à boudins il
suffit maintenant pour notre apprentie
pâtissière de découper la pâte en
morceaux de 10 cm puis de les façonner
avec son doigt comme ça eh ben c'est pas
mal je vais peut-être partir en vacances
du coup allez c'est parti donc on va se
mettre ça dans le four 160 160 cadres
qui hockey
[Musique]